التفكير بالاتجاه للطاقه البديله لم يكن
وليد اللحظه عند السيد اديب منذ اكثر من
12 عاما اتجه الى طاقه الشمس لتوليد
الكهرباء واليوم يعتمد السيد اديب على
الطاقه النظيفه في استخداماته مئه في
المئه متجاوزا ازمه ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء
خلال ثلاث سنوات هذول طبعا انا لانه
استخدام عالي بيت كبير مع الاسوار ومع
البوابات ومع الاستخدام ومعتمد على
الكهرباء احنا وفرنا بما يقارب حوالي
20.000 دينار خلال الثلاث سنوات الماضيه
الماضي
على طاقه الشمس والرياح بما يقارب 29% من
الطاقه المولده ظروف الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
تدفع الولاده لضروره استغلال الموارد
الطبيعيه المتجدده لتخفيف استيرادها من
الخارج فهنا واحد من اكبر المجمعات
الشمسيه في المنطقه اضافه لمشروع طاقه
الرياح في دوله تسعى الاعتماد الطاقه
البديله بدعمها تكلفه انظمه الخلايا
الشمسيه للقطاع المنزلي والسياحي والصناعي
بنسبه تصلوا الى خمسينات
اثر اقتصادي واجتماعي مباشر على المواطنين
ومساعدتهم على تحمل فاتوره الكهرباء
الشهريه ورغم الحاجه الملحه لرفع قدره
الشبكات والخطوط المولده للطاقه الشمسيه
الا ان طبيعه الاردن الجغرافيه المناسبه
لمشاريع الطاقه النظيفه اضافه لكونه واحدا
من دول الحزام الشمسي كانت الدافعه
لاستغلال موارده غير مكلفه وسط ازمه
عالميه ضاعفت من قيمه فاتوره الكهرباء
سوها جميل العربيه عمان